double ninja star the transforming ninja
star and even the 16.2 ninja star all
formidable weapons of battle but the
question remains is people really
reliable in battle against an enemy once
I have these two pieces of paper
together you're gonna wish you haven't
messed with me man look what I can do
see just stay away you just did you
really hurt and my power of wind back
off back there sharp the wings are there
move your country so much didn't mean I
said I'd matter but it's still fun I
managed sorta something to pull you out
so just to up the arsenal the craft
stick catapult the super craft stick
catapult and the dowel shooter using
clay as weapons we can launch them
across the room at various different
objects like cabinets and books with the
super spoon we pulled down and shooted
at my painting on the wall nearly hit it
although extremely dangerous
if aimed at a person the dowel shooter
is very adequate for shooting books and
other inanimate materials the dowel is
loaded into the barrel grabbed with the
tape on the end of the rubber bands
pulled back and let go with such force
that probably kill if not really hurt
you and you don't want that so don't aim
it at anyone
obviously alright guys so three new
weapons to add to the arsenal I know you
want to see them all but let me know
which one you want to see next in the
comments section down below I'm gonna
give it probably about about a week or
so before I go ahead and check on to see
you know what
has the highest thumbs up it takes about
that long for all my subscribers to
usually see or for those who want to see
the video at least the comment for the
most popular tutorial will be the one I
make next alright guys thanks for
watching I'll see you soon this blade is
sharp enough to cut a banana